[موسيقى]
الى شك كان خطوه حقيقيه تجاهها تقليل
التوترات ولا شك بان الخصومه والتوترات
بين ايران او المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ربما كان
المشكله الاساسيه في منطقه الخليج العربي
والمرتبطه بالنزاع المسلح وسكلد الدماء
سواء بشكل غير مباشر خاصه في حرب اليمن
القوه الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه منخرطه فيه والحوتين
بجانب الاخر مدعومون من ايران وكذلك اشكال
مباشره مثل اطلاق الصواريخ والمسارات ضد
مشاه نفط السعوديه في عام 2019
واغلب المراقبين استنتجوا بان ايران
مسؤوله عن ذلك فاذا ما
اذا كان هنالك تحت العلاقات بين هاتين
القوه الاساسيتين في جانبي الخليج العربي
فلا شك بان هذه خطوه تجاهك المنطقه اكثر
السلامه واستقرارا
[موسيقى]
فعلت ما فعلته لان لديها علاقات مع الجميع
في المنطقه تماما كما لديها مع كافه
المناطق العالم ولا تحاول ان تقسم العالم
الى اصدقاء واعداء ونتحدث فقط عن الاصدقاء
وتتجاهل ولا دعوه كان هذا هو الاساس
الدبلوم
شاهدناه لتحقيق العلاقه تحسينها بين ايران
والسعوديه الولايات المتحده كانت تفعل نفس
الشيء اذا ما اتبعت سياسي مشابهه لعدم
تقسيم العالم الى اصدقاء واعداء والتحدث
مع الجميع ولكن سي امريكا كانت غير ذلك
هنا في الشرق الاوسط لا يوجد اي حوار او
حديث ما عدا على مسارات ضيقه مثلا مع
ايران ولا تجد اي محادثات مع النظام
السوري في دمشق
وبالتالي فان الولايات المتحده لم تضع
اساسي في موقف لتحقيق مثل هذه الانجازات
لو وسعت مقاربتها
[موسيقى]